how's it going bros - welcome to call of
duty black ops right you weren't
expecting this so I love call of duty
but the PC version is always neglected
but I feel like I want to give this a go
so let's check it out play online it's
taken a little longer
come on
ah awesome alright maybe that was my
fault I'll run it in a safer mode Jesus
Christ is taking forever
oh hey [ __ ] you crashed again Jesus to a
call of duty that actually works modern
warfare 2 I love this game I have over
900 hours of this game I'm sure it's
just as good as I remember it alright
alright alright I'm [ __ ] pumped to
play this [ __ ] again here's someone the
[ __ ] was that
Oh awesome
no that's teleportation that's a new
feature come on man
what the [ __ ] is this
okay clearly nostalgia was doing its
magic on me paid paid a $60 for this 60
$60 for a game
you